[Music]
for decades the guideline for most women
to begin getting screened for breast
cancer starts at age 40 but there are
many women getting diagnosed with cancer
who are much younger than that denise
valdez introduces us to a woman who
discovered her own just in the nick of
time in today's buddy check report
the woman you'll meet in this story has
no family history of breast cancer no
genetic markers and she's young in her
early 30s but she got a mammogram just
to check out a benign cyst that she's
had since she was a teenager but it
wasn't that screening that discovered
her cancer but something she did herself
the radiologist wants to speak to you i
already know she knew she had cancer
after feeling a hard pea-sized lump in
her breast but just two months earlier
her mammogram was clear i can positively
say
and i am the the key witness to it that
self-breast exam saved my life dr
lightning is a primary care physician
with her own practice
samantha
hi
how are you so she knows the importance
of routine screenings but at 33 with no
family history no genetic markers no
need really for a mammogram but once she
felt that lump it turned her world
upside down from the time that i had my
first appointment with my oncologist
to the time that i actually started
chemotherapy
my breast tumor doubled in size the
diagnosis ductal carcinoma an aggressive
and fast growing breast cancer she's
sharing her journey on social media
starting with chemotherapy
losing her hair
then heading straight to surgery for a
double mastectomy the key to survival
and not dying from it is catching it
early and starting treatment early which
is exactly what dr lightning did and
warns other women not to ignore their
own bodies it's worth it it's worth your
life it's worth your health the next
step for dr lightning is reconstructive
surgery for buddy check denise valdez
live local now